CONVENING THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE
ON BUDGET WE WILL BE HEARING --
THIS IS A JOINT INFORMATIONAL
COMMITTEE WITH ASSEMBLY LOCAL
GOLF.
IS OUR ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOV CHAIR
HERE
-- WE WILL -- ASKED PART OF
FINANCE TO COME ON UP WILL BE
TALKING ABOUT SB. ONE NO TWO OUR
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS TRAILER
BILL.
AGAIN THIS BILL BUILT ON THE
SUCCESS OF LAST YEAR'S HEAP
PROGRAM BY ESTABLISHING THE
HOMELESS.
HOUSING ASSISTANCE A PREVENTION
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
JURISDICTIONS THE SIX HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION TO ADDRESS THE
MEDIA HOMELESS CHALLENGES.
AS WELL AS PROVIDE STREAMLINING
FOR LOW BARRIER NAVIGATIONS ARE
DEVELOPMENTS.
THAT ALSO CREATES LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TRYING TO SUPPORT
GRANT PROGRAMS TO ALLOCATE. TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
REGION'S JURISDICTIONS TO
CONDUCT PLAN THE ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THE SIX CYCLE OF
REGIONAL HOUSING NEEDS
ASSESSMENT SO WITH THAT --
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I'LL BRIEFLY DESCRIBE AT THREE
MAJOR ELEMENTS IN THIS BILL IN
THAT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
WITH MY COLLEAGUE DANIEL WHO'S
ALSO HERE.
THE FIRST IS THE ELEMENTS
RELATED TO NEW HOUSING FUNDING --
MOST OF THIS FUNDING IS ONE TIME
FUNDING AND IT ADDS UP TO ONE
POINT SEVEN FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT TOTAL TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IS FOR PLANNING
GRANTS FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS.
DIVIDED EQUALLY WITH AND
REGIONAL AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
ALLOCATED FOR EACH. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IS FOR THE INFO
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
RESPONDING TO THE NEED THAT
OFTEN HOUSING IS NOT BUILT
BECAUSE THE LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE
AROUND WHERE HOUSING MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE BUILT IS NOT THERE
TO SUPPORT IT SAID THIS HELP
SOLVE THAT ISSUE.
I SHOULD ADD THAT WITHIN THAT
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
THE AND FOR INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAMS
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS IS SET
ASIDE FOR RURAL INFRASTRUCTURE --
THESE ARE COUNTIES WITH FEWER
THAN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE I IN ADDITION THERE'S
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS TO
CAL HFA FOR THE NEXT INCOME LOAN
PROGRAM.
AND FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
TO EXPAND THE LOW INCOME HOUSING
TAX CREDIT -- AS WELL WITHIN OUR
HOUSING PROGRAMS THERE ARE
PROGRAMS THAT AWARD BONUS POINTS
FOR JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE
REALLY STACKING STEPPING UP AND
TAKING THE WEIGHT ON HOUSING --
WITH REGARD TO HOMELESSNESS --
THE OVERALL BUDGET INCLUDES
ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW
INVESTMENT.
IN THIS TRAILER BILL BEFORE YOU
INCLUDES ABOUT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT.
OF THAT TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IS FOR WHAT'S
KNOWN AS THE BIG THIRTEEN CITIES
SAID THESE ARE THE THIRTEEN
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA WITH OVER
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
THEM.
A ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IS ALLOCATED TO
COUNTIES ONE HUNDRED NINETY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THESE
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE THESE ARE
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED AREAS AND
THEN FINALLY TEN MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE PROGRAMS.
AT A LATER DATE -- AND THEN IN
ADDITION -- AFTER NEGOTIATIONS
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
LEGISLATORS AND LEGISLATIVE
STAFF -- WE'VE EXPANDED THE USES
OF THIS FUNDING SO THAT THE
LOCAL LEVEL CAN BE FLEXIBLE
FINALLY -- AFTER A LOT OF
CONVERSATION -- WE'VE REFINED AT
THE ADMINISTRATION -- SOME OF
THE REMEDIES FOR JURISDICTIONS
THAT ARE NOT IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE HOUSING ELEMENT LAW AND THIS
INCLUDES ONLY AFTER THE ORDER OF
A COURT AND AFTER AN ADDITIONAL
YEAR HAS ELAPSED SOME FINES AS
WELL AS THE POSSIBILITY THAT THE
COURT MAY APPOINT AN AGENT. TO
BRING THAT JURISDICTION TO GO
INTO COMPLIANCE SO THOSE ARE
THREE OF THE KEY AREAS AND WE'RE
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER WHAT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
CATTLE ONLY APPEAR.
LIKE TOMORROW IS A HOLIDAY OR
SOMETHING.
I HAD A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT --
THE BILL AND LET ME START BY
TALKING FOCUSING ON THE PART
THAT GIVES THE STATE REMEDIES
INCLUDING FINDS IN APPOINTING AN
AGENT OF THE COURT -- FOR
BRINGING CITIES INTO COMPLIANCE
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE ONLY PENALIZING CITIES FOR
THESE ELEMENTS OF THEIR HOUSING
ELEMENT THAT ARE UNDER THEIR
CONTROL -- THINGS LIKE ZONING
AND PLANNING AND NOT FOR BECAUSE
I KNOW THE GOVERNOR ORIGINALLY
HAD PROPOSED WITH THE SP ONE
MONEY TO PENALIZE CITIES FOR
FAILING TO PRODUCE HOUSING.
WHICH I THINK WAS UNFAIR BECAUSE
IT PENALIZES PERSON SOMETHING
CITIES FOR SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
IN THEIR CONTROL YOU KNOW THE
THE ACTUAL PRODUCTION HOUSING
WHICH IS NOT THE CITY'S JOB.
SO THIS IS JUST FOR THE ZONING
AND PLANNING ELEMENTS OF THE
HOUSING ELEMENT FREE CITY RIGHT
THAT'S CORRECT THIS BILL IS FOR
COMPLIANCE WITH THE EXISTING
HOUSING ELEMENT LAW SO IT DOES
NOT HAVE THAT PRODUCTION IT AS A
PRODUCTION GOAL -- BUT THE LEGAL
STANDARD IS WHETHER YOUR ZONING
AND PLANNING FOR THE HOUSING AS
PRESCRIBED BY LAW.
OKAY THANK YOU AND I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE GRANT FUNDING SO WE'VE
GOT TO BIG POOLS OF MONEY HERE
WE GOT THE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANT PROGRAM AND THEN THE HAP.
PROGRAM -- WE HAD ASKED FOR A
SET ASIDE FOR SMALL AND RURAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES FOR BOTH
PROGRAMS AND I'M VERY HAPPY THAT
WE GOT THAT 18% SET ASIDE.
FOR A INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE BUT
THE THE THAT WE DID NOT GET THAT
SET ASIDE FOR THE HALF PROGRAM
IS THAT CORRECT.
DON'T BELIEVE SO OR TURNED OVER
TO MY COLLEAGUE.
DANIELLE BRENDA DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I DON'T BELIEVE WE SET A
MINIMUM FOR THE SMALL
JURISDICTIONS.
OKAY.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT'S KIND OF A
PROBLEM BECAUSE THE SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS ALSO HAVE A LARGE
AND GROWING HOMELESS PROBLEM.
THEIR PARTS OF MY DISTRICT WHERE
WE'RE SEEING HOMELESSNESS WHERE
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN HOMELESSNESS
IN THE PAST.
AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE
SMALLER JURISDICTIONS TO COMPETE
WITH BIG JURISDICTIONS LIKE LOS
ANGELES FOR THESE FUNDS SO -- I
I REALLY HOPE THAT IN THE FUTURE
WE LOOK AT AT MAKING IT EASIER
FOR THOSE SMALLER JURISDICTIONS
TO COMPETE AND SETTING ASIDE A
PORTION OF THE MONEY. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PROBLEM GETS
ADDRESSED IN THOSE PORTIONS OF
THE STATE AS WELL.
THANK YOU ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
[inaudible]
MR LOOK.
I'M THINKING BACK -- TO I THINK
IT WAS TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHEN WE
PASSED THE OF BIG HOUSING
PACKAGE AND PART OF THAT WAS A.
B.. SEVENTY TWO I THINK IT WAS
MISTER SANTIAGO IS LEGISLATION
ON ENFORCEMENT.
HOW DO THESE THINGS WORK
TOGETHER?
CENTS EXIST I GUESS THE QUESTION
IS HOW DOES THE EXISTING
ENFORCEMENT MECHANISM WORK
TOGETHER WITH WHAT'S BEING
PROPOSED.
SURE FOR H. CD'S THE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THE EIGHTY
SEVEN SORRY AB SEVENTY TWO HOT
PIE TO EACH CITIES REVIEW AND OF
THE COMPLY -- THE HOUSING
ELEMENT OVERALL THIS -- TRAILER
BILL.
REFERS TO WHAT HAPPENS AFTER
EACH CITIES CONTINUED EFFORTS TO
GET A JURISDICTION INTO
COMPLIANCE.
SO THIS WOULD BE -- JUDICIAL
REMEDIES AFTERTHOUGHT REMEDIES
AFTER -- AB SEVENTY TWO HAS BEEN
EXHAUSTED.
SO SEQUENTIAL THEN THIS DOESN'T
COME INTO PLAY.
UNTIL AFTER A BEAST THE REMEDIES
UNDER AB SEVENTY TWO ARE
COMPLETELY.
YEAH I GUESS I'LL MAKE -- TWO
POINTS ABOUT IT FIRST IS THAT IN
THOSE REMEDY STILL EXIST -- BUT
THIS CLARIFIES THE PROCEDURE
BEFORE THE PARTIES ENTER INTO
ANY TYPE OF LAWSUIT BECAUSE
THERE ARE THERE'S A NOTIFICATION
REQUIREMENT THAT A TV HAS TO
HAVE TWO MEETINGS WITH THE
JURISDICTION THAT IT BELIEVES IS.
OUT OF COMPLIANCE AND THEN THE
SECOND THING THAT THIS BILL DOES
THERE'S A LOT OF FOCUS ON THE
REMEDIES AND YOU KNOW HOW THEY
CAN BE ENFORCED AGAINST A
JURISDICTION.
BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES THE
ELEMENTS THAT IF THE COURT
DECIDES THAT THE JURISDICTION
HAS COME BACK INTO SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE.
EVEN IF EIGHT C. D. MIGHT
CONTEST AT DETERMINATION THAT
COURTS AT DETERMINATION WOULD
GOVERN.
OKAY THANK YOU.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS IN FAVOR OF
THE PROPOSAL.
MR ON WITH THE GOOD MISTER RAMOS
EXCUSE ME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
SORRY FOR THE DELAYED.
REACTION TO YOUR QUESTION BUT
I'M I DID COME IN A LITTLE BIT
LATE NOT SURE IF YOU COVERED IT
BUT AND SOME OF THE BACKGROUND
MATERIAL THERE IS A CUT OFF WITH --
POPULATIONS OF CITIES -- TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND ARE.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND SO.
ASKING THE QUESTION HOW DID WE
ARRIVE AT THAT POPULATION CUT
OFF.
WHEN?
YOU KNOW.
THE AREA THAT I SERVE THE
FOURTEENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT THE
CITY OF SABATINO HAS A HIGH --
POPULATION OF HOMELESSNESS AND
NEEDS ARE THERE BUT YET UNDER
THAT CRITERIA THEY WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO QUALIFY FOR THE MAJOR --
FUNDING STREAM OF THAT SO.
HOW DID WE REACH THAT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND POPULATION
VERSUS?
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND I'LL MAKE A
COUPLE POINTS DURING THE FIRST
MOST IMPORTANT IS THAT THAT
FUNDING WHILE SIGNIFICAN IS
ACTUALLY STILL LESS THAN HALF OF
THE OVERALL HOMELESS THIS
FUNDING SO.
AT THIS TRAILER BILL HAS SIX
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN
TOTAL -- AND THAT AMOUNT IS TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION SO
IT IS A BIG POT BUT IT IS STILL
LESS THAN HALF OF THE OVERALL
BEFORE YOU.
ARE THE SECOND IS -- SO LAST
YEAR'S PROGRAM WHICH WAS CALLED
A HEAP I BELIEVE IT'S A HOMELESS
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS.
THAT ALLOCATED -- FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OVERALL VERY SIX
FIFTEEN THE BILL BEFORE YOU --
AND POT THAT WAS SEQUESTERED FOR
BIG CITIES HAD THE BIGGEST
ELEVEN CITIES -- SO WE ACTUALLY
DROPPED -- IN THIS YEAR'S ACTION
THE POPULATION LOWER INITIALLY
WAS HIGHER THAN THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND NOW WE DROPPED TWO TO
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND THAT
ACCOMPLISHED -- TO ADDITIONAL
CITIES SO NOW RATHER THAN THE
ELEVEN BIGGEST CITIES INCLUDES
THE THIRTEENTH BIGGEST CITIES --
INCLUDING STOPPED AND AND I
BELIEVE RIVERSIDE IS THE OTHER
CITY THAT WAS INCLUDED -- BUT WE
DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT YOU
KNOW THE ADMINISTRATION DEAD
DOES BOY THAT THOSE CITIES HAVE
UNIQUE NEEDS THAT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED -- BUT THE BALANCE OF
THE FUNDING MORE THAN HALF GOES
TO COUNTIES AND GOES TO THE
CONVENIENCE OF CARE WHICH ARE
THESE FEDERALLY DESIGNATED
JURISDICTIONS THAT.
GO ACROSS THE STATE AND SO --
ALL AREAS OF THE STATE WILL BE
ABLE TO APPLY FOR THAT MONEY.
SO EVEN -- WITH WITH THAT
EXPLOSION THROUGH THE CHAIR --
IT TOOK ABOUT HOW IT'S NOT IN
THE FUNDING.
TO TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THERE'S A THE THE NUMBER
THAT'S THERE BUT YET IT'S ONLY
THIRTEEN CITIES OUT OF OVER.
FOUR HUNDRED SO.
IF THERE IS -- ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AS FAR AS MAYBE NOW
OR OR AS FAR AS LOOKING AT
POPULATIONS OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND PLUS.
WITH THEN START -- TO ACCOUNT
FOR MAYBE. TWENTY TWO CITIES OUT
OF FOUR HUNDRED STARTING TO HAVE
AN IMPACT.
I'M JUST BRINGING THAT UP
BECAUSE WE'VE SEEN -- PRIOR AT
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND NOW AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FOR THE AREA HOW THE HOMELESS
POPULATION CONTINUES TO GROW.
AND HOW.
FUNDING CONTINUES TO BE
DETERMINED AND GO ELSEWHERE WHEN
WE'RE FACED WITH THE SAME
SITUATIONS -- WITHIN WITHIN OUR
AREAS SO -- WE WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE FURTHER DIALOGUE TO SEE IF
WE CAN'T FIGURE OUT SOME ON THE
THE POPULATION BASE IN THE CHIU
NEEDS A OF THE CITIES THAT ARE
BEING IMPACTED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ABSOLUTELY NOT JUST ON THIS FROM
LOCAL CLARIFY SO.
ON COUNTIES -- WILL BE GETTING A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
SO AGAIN OBVIOUSLY.
THAT THE CITIES THAT ARE NOT IN
THE BIG THIRTEEN SHOULD
DEFINITELY WORK WITH THE COUNTY
IS.
TO GET APPROPRIATE HELP IN
ADDITION A HUNDRED AND NINETY
MILLION WHEN TO CONTINUUM'S OF
CARE.
IN EVERY COUNTY OR OR REGION HAS
A CONTINUUM OF CARE AND SO FOR
CITIES ARE STARTING TO SEE THAT
IMPACT I WOULD DEFINITELY.
ASK THEM TO WORK WITH THEIR
CONTEMPT OF CARE TO REALLY DEAL
WITH THIS ISSUE ON THE OTHER THE
OTHER REASON THERE IS SUCH A
FOCUS ON THE LARGE THIRTEEN
CITIES.
HI I BELIEVE THEY HAVE ABOUT.
75% OR SO OF THE ENTIRE HOMELESS
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SO AGAIN DIDN'T GET 75% OF THE
MONEY THEY THEY WOULD HAVE LOVED
THAT.
BUT WE THOUGHT THAT THIS MAKES
WAS WAS APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
NEED IN AGAIN -- THE CITIES OF
THESE CITIES WERE THE ONES THAT
REALLY BY FAR HAVE THE LARGEST --
POPULATIONS OF HOMELESS PEOPLE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXPLANATION
OF MISTER CHAIR AND LOOK FORWARD
TO FURTHER DIALOGUE THANK YOU.
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
MISS AGUIAR-CURRY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I'M
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS BILL AS A
PACKAGE -- IT MAKES SENSE TO ME
TO FIRST INCENTIVIZE LOCAL.
AGENCIES THAT TO DO BETTER
PLANNING.
I'M HAVE YOU SEE THE PLAN
SUPPORTS GRANTS PROGRAM AND ALSO
THE IN FILL INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT
PROGRAM OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
IN THE TRAILER BILL.
I'M ESPECIALLY HAPPY THAT RURAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE A SATISFIED
IN SOME FLEXIBILITY IN THE
INTEREST IN FILL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM.
THE SMALL CITIES AND TOWNS THAT
I REPRESENT HAVE DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES ATTRACTING IN
DELIVERING HOUSING AND THE
PROGRAM ACKNOWLEDGES THIS.
THIS BILL WILL GIVE LOCAL
AGENCIES A CHANCE TO USE THIS
FUNDING TO IMPROVE LOCAL
PLANNING.
STREAMLINED LOCAL PROCESSES AND
LAY THE FOUNDATION FOR ACTUALLY
DELIVERING HOUSING.
INITIALLY I HAD CONCERNS ABOUT
COURT ACTIONS AGAINST LOCALS
WHERE THE LINE IS DRAWN FOR
LOCAL CONTROL.
IF THE GOAL IS ACCOMPLISHING
HOUSING ELEMENT COMPLIANCE THE
THE GRADUALLY ESCALATING
REMEDIES AND THE MULTIPLE
AVENUES FOR A CITY OR COUNTY TO
CORRECT ITS COURSE ALONG THE WAY
GIVE ME MUCH MORE COMFORT.
I ALSO APPRECIATE THE LANGUAGE
THE ALLOWS THE COURT TO CONSIDER
MITIGATING CIRCUMSTANCES OF WHY
IS CITY OR COUNTY MAY NOT BE IN
COMPLIANCE.
OUR CURRENT TEN TENDENCIES TO
LUMP LOCALS WHO ARE STRUGGLING
TO ATTRACTED DELIVER HOUSING
WITH THOSE TO PUT UP BARRIERS TO
DEVELOP IS COUNTERPRODUCTIVE.
FOR FOR FOR THE FORMER THE
CARROTS IN THIS PACKAGE WILL
ACCOMPLISH OUR GOAL. FOR THE
LATTER I JOIN WITH MY COLLEAGUES
WHO WANT TO FORCE RESPONSIBLE
DELIVERY OF THE HOUSING OUR
STATE DESPERATELY NEEDS.
I WANT TO THANK THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE AND STAFF TO
ADMINISTRATION IS THE SENATE
LEADERSHIP THE BUT AT THE BUDGET
CHAIRS A BUDGET STAFF.
AND MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT STUFF
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER.
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
WE'LL GO TO PUBLIC COME AT THE
START THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICOLE
ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SAN BERNADINO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE HOMELESSNESS FUNDING.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LEGISLATURE'S
PROPOSALS AS WELL AS ALL OF THE
STAFF WORK THAT HAS GONE INTO
THIS PACKAGE.
IN TERMS OF ORANGE COUNTY WE ARE
PARTICULARLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CHANGES TO THE LOCAL HOUSING
TRUST FUND LANGUAGE ALLOWING SB
THREE AS A MATCH.
AND FOR SAN BERNARDINO COUNTY WE
ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF THE
FUNDING GOING TO BOTH COUNTIES
AND CEO SEES.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES STRONGLY SUPPORT OF THE
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION FOR THE HOMELESS AID
PROGRAM.
ESPECIALLY THE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLAR
ALLOCATION DIRECTLY TO COUNTIES
COUNTIES ARE THE SAFETY NET
PROVIDERS FOR THE STATE WE THINK
THEY'RE VERY WELL POSITIONED TO
IDENTIFY THE GAPS IN OUR CURRENT
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORT THE
HOMELESS.
AND BETTER TACKLE THE CRISIS
STATEWIDE WE'RE ALSO VERY
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM.
ESPECIALLY THE 18% SET ASIDE FOR
AN OVER THE COUNTER PROCESS FOR
MORE RURAL SMALLER JURISDICTIONS --
IN PRIOR ROUNDS OF THE INFILL
INFRASTRUCTURE GRANT PROGRAM
THERE'D BEEN VERY FEW
APPLICATIONS AWARDED TO PROJECTS
IN UNINCORPORATED AREAS BUT THEY
HAVE THE SAME OBLIGATION TO PLAN
FOR HOUSING SO WE'RE REALLY
EXCITED NOT JUST ABOUT THAT SET
ASIDE.
BUT ALSO ABOUT THE THE WORK THAT
THE COMMITTEE DID IN COMING UP
WITH A BROADER INFILL DEFINITION
THAT WILL REALLY HELP THOSE
COMMUNITIES ALSO DELIVER HOUSING.
FINALLY WHILE WE DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PRECEDENT
SETTING NATURE OF THE HOUSING
ELEMENT ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS
WE ARE NEUTRAL ON THAT ASPECT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
CAN LOS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YEAR
THAN WHEN I APPRECIATE THE
LANGUAGE AROUND THE LOW BARRIER
NAVIGATION CENTER IS INCLUDED IN
THE BILL AS WELL AS THE
CONTINUATION OF A SET ASIDE FOR
YOU -- AT 8% AND THERE AND
REALLY APPRECIATE THE DEFINITION
THAT MATCHES -- OTHER POLICY
AREAS THAT WERE CAPTURING MINORS --
UNDER EIGHTEEN AND YOUTH OVER
EIGHTEEN AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE SPECIFIC PROGRAMS DESIGNED
FOR THEM AS WELL AS ENSURING
THAT THE DOLLARS ARE BEING USED
IN COORDINATION LOCALLY.
SO THAT WERE REALLY
COMPLEMENTING THE EFFORTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN GOING TO PLAN
AN ADDRESS AND AND HOMELESSNESS
THANK YOU.
JR MEMBERS ROSS BUT THE ON
BEHALF OF SOUTH AMERICA GAL
STAMBERG LIKE TO THINK THAT
MINISTRATION BOTH HOUSES FOR THE
ON GOING -- HOMELESS ON THE GOOD
MORNING CHAIRS AND MEMBERS
MARINO WENT WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESSING THE
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS CRISES
AND THE STATE -- BUT I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T JUST NOTE
THAT AS CO SPONSORS OF AB
SEVENTY TWO WE DO THINK THAT
THERE MIGHT BE SOME CONFLICTS
BETWEEN THE GOALS OF THE
ADMINISTRATION.
AND THE GOALS OF AB SEVENTY TWO
AND A LIKE TO KIND OF FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO CLEAN CLEAN UP THAT
LANGUAGE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING BILL HIGGINS WITH
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION COUNCILS
OF GOVERNMENTS -- HERE TO
SUPPORT THE PLANNING LANGUAGE IN
THE PLANNING FUNDING IN THE BILL
IN THE INFILL INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDS WE THINK THAT.
THIS WILL NOT ONLY HELP AUGMENT
THE LOCAL EFFORTS ON THE GROUND
IN THE AREAS WHERE THE ARE GOING
TO BE ASKED TO PRODUCE THE
HIGHEST AMOUNT OF PRODUCTION IT
WILL ALSO HELP COMMUNITIES.
THROUGH REGIONAL RESOURCES THAT --
MAY NOT HAVE THE THE RESOURCES
ON THEIR OWN BECAUSE THEY'RE
VERY SMALL THAT WILL BE ABLE TO
AUGMENT THEIR EFFORTS.
AND ALSO WILL BE ABLE TO TAILOR
THIS IN WITH OUR CLIMATE GOAL SO
THE IDEA IS THAT.
WE CAN PROVIDE SOME REGIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO THIS MONEY
BECAUSE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS NOT THE SAME
STRATEGY YOU NEED IN THE BAY
AREA WILL HAVE SOME OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO REPORTING OUT. TO YOU
ABOUT OUR SUCCESSES IN THAT
EFFORT THANK YOU [inaudible]
JEFF TORTILLA [inaudible]
ADVOCATES -- ANYTHING WE DO FOR
HOMELESS ANYTHING WE CAN DO
ABOUT UNDERSTANDING BETTER --
I'M HOPING THAT NON PROFITS WILL
BE INCLUDED.
IN THERE PARTICULARLY BECAUSE
YOU'RE STILL NEED TO MEANS OF
ADDRESSING WHAT ON THE UNDER ONE
THOUSAND DOLLAR.
RENTAL MARKET SO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACCESSIBLE HOUSING IS
SOMETHING THAT IS BECOMING A
PRIMARY IMPORTANCE ITS TO TEN
YEARS FOR THIS.
IT'LL PROBABLY TAKE YOU TEN
YEARS TO GET CLOSER ON IT BUT
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU JUST QUICK QUICK
COMMENT ON THE NONPROFIT TO
DEFINITELY INCLUDED IN THE
CONTINUES OF CARE.
SOURCE OF FUNDING IN OBVIOUSLY
THE FUNDING DOESN'T EXCLUDE
CITIES OR COUNTIES FROM WORKING
WITH NON PROFITS [inaudible]
ANY OTHER.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
OKAY.
SEEING NONE WE'LL -- WILL TURN
THIS THIS BILL WILL BE --
BROUGHT UP ON THE FLOOR ON
FRIDAY